[Music]
ring uh ring ring ring ring ring
welcome to team coco lives moses and
friends i am your host moses storm
tonight we're partnering with hbo max to
talk to some of the comedians behind
their new hbo max specials are going to
get inside looks to be a very fun show
you also notice that throughout the show
we're going to be enjoying some
beverages
provided by hbo max if you sent me a fun
little note in lieu of payment please
accept alcohol
okay it's a very loose show it's
essentially like you're hanging out with
comics all night backstage in the green
room
uh to talk about her special horned dog
we're going to bring on
rose matafeo beth stelling's going to be
here with her special girl
daddy and then the host of the art of
comedy it's another special
angela johnson is gonna be here oh but
first i'm gonna bring on my friend chris
rad because chris
and i are in a pretty unique situation
with our hbo max specials where we're
trying to figure out a way to shoot them
uh because we're doing this show
virtually by the way we're doing this
show virtually because it's uh it's very
dangerous to be in a comedy club right
now
especially for young people i mean you
just never know what 40 year old
male comedian that looks 50 but dresses
like he's 20 and dates like he's 15
could be hiding around any corner she's
like oh we didn't see you there
bud why are you dressed like a greasy
magician
no we're doing this show virtually
because obviously a pandemic is just
ripping through this country
the economy is in shambles people are
really hurting and hbo thought
you know what would help people out
right now another
paid streaming service what is hbo max
well despite popular belief hbo max is
not a line of feminine hygiene products
i know it gets confusing because there
is hbo max hbo go hbo
family hbo plus plus disney comcast and
the sorcerer's stone
if hbo starts another streaming service
warner media is going to have to call
marie condua
hbo which one of these gritty murder
docs
does not spark joy now i downloaded it
it's actually great it's essentially hbo
but it has a lot more shows comedy
specials
and uh just like original movies it's
they have a lot it's creepy it's creepy
how much hbo max has i mean hbo max even
has hidden camera footage of me sleeping
from 2009 critics are calling that
footage
already more engaging than season two of
true detective
the other new streaming service new on
the block is peacock and they're
revamping an old series
it's a variety show featuring comedians
it's called
to catch a predator peacock is like your
aunt that gets out of rehab and promises
that this time
it's gonna be different i am not gonna
piss away
my money oh look a save by the bell
reboot
no go home aunt ceso can't do any more
reboots
that's why hbo max is here they have so
much new stuff coming your way
speaking of chris and i are trying to
tape our new one-hour specials with hbo
max
let's bring chris in chris i am here i
have always been here i
do not leave how far were you in the
process
of finishing your special before the
whole shutdown happened i was
so close man i was like five jokes away
from a full
hour uh and then they were like hey
if you sneeze you die i get in the house
and i was like all right
damn okay cool yeah and a lot of the
jokes don't carry over like i had a joke
that was like black people don't get
coronavirus
uh which didn't age well at all
i mean my my whole set was about how you
know covet is a hoax and it's gonna go
away in april oh so then that means that
trump just stole your material
so it's it's it's honestly comedy
just gone to another level yeah you and
i were talking last night
about even if we got the green light
tomorrow we still need to tour before
to essentially work out uh the specials
yeah maybe an outdoor
show have you done anything that's like
outdoor or virtual shows
yeah outside shows are cool but i didn't
i didn't feel
good it without a top hat turned upside
down to collect money afterwards
no it feels like it just feels like
you're just yelling outside
uh yeah i i've looked at the outdoor
shows where it's just like a guy yelling
in a field i can't do outdoor shows
because the way i look
if i yell at people in a field people
think i'm just announcing the rules to
an ultimate frisbee game
it's about to start all right no attack
backs we got double ups no touches
this guy loves it i can't perform in the
field because you perform for free and
working free in the field would not make
my ancestors proud it set me back a lot
no not the time for that no not to move
forward
this is cool so a lot of people got sent
uh the
gift box from hbo max yes i did stacks i
think oh this is cool
i you know hbo max sent me one too sort
of a no hard feelings for all the hbo
max
jokes very nice of them i love it man yo
i'm honestly very excited about this
they sent me a lot of cool stuff to send
me two tickets
two tickets to nowhere this is my first
time getting two tickets
this game is very exciting to have
tickets to a mandatory work meeting
oh they sent me some uh liquor they sent
me some ginger buck
svc gingerbread and some matador
vodka um
i don't know if they got my i don't have
the i just have
one for loco in mine not with or
testosterone i think these are legal you
shouldn't be
doing that well they got me boom
my my baby my favorite my bullet bourbon
and they got me a black label johnny
welcome
they know how to treat again bottles uh
he just sent me a loose bag of vodka
oh i wouldn't drink that oh i got a full
bottle that's not all oh god it is a
piping hot flat diet mountain dew left
in a kia sorrento
mountain dew is the only only piss fba
approved to drink that's dope
did you get any snacks i did uh i was
about to show you my uh
my organic grapes i didn't even know you
could send grapes in the mail and they
and they did
smell so great oh i got snacks i got
starbursts
oh that's kind of dope
it's just yellow it's just the worst one
oh that sound hey yellow's not terrible
it's just sheepish
i got some skinny pop they sent me a
leaking can of tuna
oh they don't like you dog i feel like
they don't like you
they sent me they sent me a dna kit just
in case
they just sent me a bunch of squirrel
dna in parts
but what purpose oh no
uh i'm not getting any oh they did send
me some apple product
oh it's just 11 iphone 4s with 2020
software so they don't work
oh but but if you you know if you time
travel then you
you'll be able to to talk to everybody
in one specific year
they sent me an emmy for no reason i
don't even deserve this
this is crazy i didn't even package it
up with nothing this seems really mean
they just sent me
a 2020 calendar and planner already
filled out with nothing
hey at least you don't got to fill it
out you know what i mean
yeah kindle so i can read books without
owning them
they sent me some fun packing paper yeah
it matches my pubic
hair uh my box is just lined with actual
human hair who whose hair is that
it says john travolta ojfx
i don't know um well you know how your
hollywood career by the end
oh i spoke to you soon they sent me an
ipad
uh nope it's empty box it just has true
detective season two in it
that explains the blood pocket they just
sent me those shoes that every white
sitcom comedy writer wears oh man those
are gonna be great for the live action
version of doug they sent me
jays baby some fresh ass js
oh and there's tickets to the nba bubble
[Music]
well this is dope oh they make my dreams
come true
thank you hbo max when's the game
oh right now i gotta go man have fun
with your little zoom you know whatever
whatever the [ __ ] this is oh uh okay
well that was
uh chris living everyone's dream comedy
special coming
soon hopefully to hbo max i want to
bring in my first guest
she's got a great special on hbo max
called horndog
please welcome bros matafio rose thank
you so much for for being here and doing
thank you for having me thank you so
much are you enjoying your
uh two cocktails yeah i'm enjoying my
mine at once
i've got my cocktail in a mug oh look at
that discreet so
has struggled with alcoholism before i
kill you
yeah it's a mug it wasn't a paper a bag
before um i it is 8 a.m
in new zealand okay great for a
gingerbreak they say
is it is it great is it like is it not
okay to drink at 80 and i should be
drinking
i i think in quarantine rules no it's
completely fine at any time
anytime i i drank i drink a lot a lot of
time
let's be real i'm getting really close
to the camera
i drank a lot yeah i lived with my um my
nan i locked down with my
70 76 year old uh grandmother
and um we we got on it we definitely got
on it we um we'd make a new cocktail
every night
we had some we had a spritz night
learned how to make
martinis we got steamed actually yeah it
was great
this is great this is good energy i'll
be doing it's a great energy
i mean i think your nan should be
hosting this i'm
talking myself out of a job here get her
in get her a
whole bottle of whatever she wants a
giant coffee mug
i was watching your special and one
thing that really stood out to me
is how present you were with the crowd
during that special i feel like a lot of
times people are recording their special
like
okay i'm immortalizing my dream
everything needs to be worked perfect
and i can count at least 12 times where
you stop down and
you address whatever was happening in
that room is that something that you had
planned on before
is that a product of the festival it's
just it's very rare to see
that that's a that's yeah i never really
thought about that that's um
i think it definitely is a product of
the festival before the shows
in edinburgh oh actually all of the
shows i play uh ping pong
um like i play table tennis with the
crowd before i'd start
and it's something i just started doing
in edinburgh like i did that
for horndog and then the year before i
would go around and make labels for
everyone on my label maker yeah and meet
the crowd
sneakily i think it's a way of like
reminding that crowd that i'm a human
being
and they're about to see an hour from a
real person
that wants you to love them um
but you know and it breaks down some
some type of barrier where it's like
it does break down something where it's
like this is a kind of um
an exchange rather than me just talking
at you and
i hope that comes across i find
so much trouble in naming things how'd
you come up with horn dog it's kind of a
happy accident
it's um yeah it's really hard to name
things i named it because i just thought
it was a really funny
name and word it was and it came i think
that
you know when you come up with a name
and you kind of come up with the idea
for the show
yeah that kind of happened but it's so
funny because it's like
it was genuinely one of the it was the
year that i was like i'm just gonna
choose a stupid name
and that would be funny to do like a
silly name uh
and then that now has become the kind of
title and
i guess word and concept that has been
incredibly
linked to my career as a stand-up um i
don't know as a reminder
that stand up is really stupid and silly
and it can be it can be silly
as as well as you know meaningful but
that those two things are just not
they're not the end of spectrum it's
like it's all kind of intertwined and so
you know a show called that
um um luckily winning uh quite a an
amazing
award felt very funny there's there's
like awards now that say horn dog on
them yeah everybody is huge literally
i've got it i got on this massive um
statue and it's engraved it's it's
rosemary
horndog yeah which is just it looks like
it's calling me a horn dog which is not
completely untrue but
no no so prestigious you want it for
being the horniest well that's what i
did like about your special too because
i think a lot of the
festival shows can be very heavy-handed
and there's just pressure to have a
theme
there's always that cadence you can tell
when someone's trying to heavily
handedly
end the show and it's not even a smart
sentence
but what they do is they slow down the
voice
to let you know all they wrote
i can't i can't handle that it might be
my
my kind of me being from new zealand and
being so deeply self-deprecating that i
could never take myself that seriously
uh to do that i i don't know if it's
that or just um
yeah i i the confidence it takes
to believe that like what i'm saying
is correct and important
to but i mean like but to be fair i mean
i i feel like all stand up is that so
it's kind of you know ridiculous to kind
of be like i'm not like that
but you know it's it's yeah it is a
little bit of a cop-out to just try to
get those awards or trying to make it an
award-winning show of like you do
this whole hour and then it's nothing
just because you use that
cadence that they use and npr completely
i think you could say anything
in that cadence and it would still sound
you could be like
milk milk lemonade
[Laughter]
fudge was made to black and everyone's
like whoa
okay wow that was huge let's put that
whole sentence
on an award i think i'm i'm i'm just
lucky because i i mean i've seen so many
so many other canadian specials and kind
of really
tried to think about what would be the
best um to represent me which turns out
it was an incredibly garish backdrop
which i was like
i was watching it and i was like geez
rose and then
the part of me was like that's exactly
you and your style of personality which
is
garish and over the top um so you know
don't lie to yourself the musical
choices too i feel like we would have
been
musical soul mates high school
keane is in there we got a cane we're
talking about
boys oh my gosh
yeah oh my gosh i mean i've got like a i
feel like i've got a guilty
not guilty but uh a playlist of you know
very much
the fallout boys the panic at the best
goes yeah even a bit of
escape
in hindsight it's so insane that because
i remember connected as a kid but now
it's just so weird to realize like oh
those guys were
30. those guys were 30 and like
incredibly
like deeply misogynistic it's so funny
like like um there's like that metro
station
um curse of curves who is that by
there's some like um i've been listening
to like the actual lyrics of these songs
and it's just a bunch of like
as you say legit 30 year old men talking
about how
uh like wiley women are
being like they'll get you they're not
the good guys
in these songs you know and it's just
like you get caught up in the insane
like we were both 16 and you felt so
like you leaving all day like you're not
over this 16 year old girl
that's half your life again
well i i miss i miss so
much that style of singing no one has
ever read jiffy lube
i want those back there great pads from
life
[Music]
debit cards but don't you find that
there is like always an affectation like
a vocal
uh style that becomes popular like i
feel like there's that kind of
indie female singer songwriter one
that's very popular now as well
which is kind of like speaking like
you've got like a plum in your mouth
like
like it's like wide like ciao
it's very yeah
like it's yeah it's it's more like a
wide
kind of equipment the voice is cracky
like uh i didn't even try
rose doing a show at 5 00 a.m
[Music]
oh i love it uh so the not only do you
have
an hbo max special which is a huge
accomplishment but you also have an hbo
max series
which is huge that's like every comic's
goal can you tell us a little bit about
the series no it's still
in the works yeah no it's still on the
way it's um it's called star struck it's
a
hbo max and bbc got together and gonna
make this
show um yeah we're gonna be making it
soon um a character i play has like a
one night stand with a very famous
person
and um i can't i can't lie writing it
was very
writing the pilot did feel like a creepy
fan fiction everyone keeps asking if
it's based on true events and i'm like
i would i honestly wish no no this is
wish fulfill this is which fulfillment
is a real celebrity that's that's in
there or is it like a
placeholder celebration no well no we've
got it we're a very very
very talented actor but um i think um i
think it probably would have hit
close to home for like an actual
big celeb also i feel like sometimes
celebs are
kind of bad at playing versions of
themselves where they have to be like
aware of
the nature of their life and job a bit
so you know it's it's good to step away
from that and kind of yeah you know it's
basically a real
celebrity i can't vote this is basically
that's
based on it julia roberts the special is
called
horndog on hbo max and then you have a
show coming out with hbo max 2 this is
all very exciting
i hope to talk to you again soon lovely
to talk to you thanks moses
thank you rose it's our two drink
minimum presented by hbo max
clean yes great to just spill this all
over my computer
oh my gosh all right cheers thanks rose
see ya my next guest is a talented
comedian who has both a critically
acclaimed half-hour special and album to
her name
already her long-awaited debut hour
special is called
girl daddy it's on hbo max please
welcome beth stelling hello beth
and experience your special tv
special drinking the ginger buck what do
you got in your
what's it called i'm having the the
the max arena yeah out of the boot
and we need these are branded drinks i
need you to say right to the camera max
read a boot and take it to the max
and if you can make a red sound like an
engine okay okay
max arena to the max
great you sounded hammered and am i
hired
it's perfect it's exactly what we were
looking for we love it
uh the girl daddy we're here to talk
about your special
in this gotcha interview welcome why why
call it uh girl daddy i feel like i know
a little bit just from watching the
special
yeah i've been called a female comic so
many times that if i have kids i'm only
answering to girl daddy that's the only
thing i'll answer too
yeah we're gonna go out of our way to
feminize these titles
yes then i'm gonna be you know it
originated actually from my nephew
it's something that he called my sister
his girl daddy
yeah he's like you're my girl daddy and
you're like that's mine
and this kid gets no money yeah and i'm
like look i can't live my life without
minding it for material
so yeah what is the true thing that
happens is like
i notice how often it doesn't even clear
things up when they bring some up as a
female comedian if anything
it brings the show to a grinding halt as
the show
hosts stumbles all over it yeah that's
jimmy we have to catch up watch out for
those raiders all right next
oh god we got a female
girls behave yourself women get out of
the room don't watch your cycles to link
up we got a female
comic coming to the stage like they're
so baffled that someone with different
parts is going to do the same job
as that it's kind of one of those things
where uh
i get i don't know what to say like we
have to maybe stop talking about it
like how are we still having the
conversation like why would i still be
getting
asked the question what's it like being
a female comic i feel like we're
self-perpetuating at this point
um yeah sorry this is getting serious
and we're looking for some real
quick bites it's asked so you have to
think about it because it is asked in
interviews and sometimes the only way to
get into these articles is i comment on
what it's like being a female comedian
right and it's like we've been freaking
doing it for a long time when i was
younger i used to answer the question
like
it's great it's an advantage i stand out
on the lineup blah blah blah blah
and then lately i've heard from some
other female family
that they don't appreciate that and that
we should be talking about that it's
more difficult or whatever it is or the
problems with it and it's like
i don't know what it'll stop females
have been killed oh maybe i should have
shut my door before this interview
uh no you have movers coming in you're
being a victim
you're a comedian in 2020 so you're
being currently evicted
also congrats on the special thank you
so much
yeah well we're doing this interview to
promote the special
um a lot of things are being repo'd from
me
yeah is there something else no longer
afford it it's happening
should i shut my front door the front
door yeah
shut the front door
is this a bit shut the front door okay
yeah
it's been shut hbo max is just like hbo
but it's very clean
a lot of succession is heavily edited
somebody somebody was like when are we
gonna get a family friendly hbo special
it's like
is that what they're known for the hbo
special genre
family friendly well this special's for
the hoes
and the dirty dogs out there dirty
special folks
i'm thankful i got it in moses i i would
be freaking out if i were you i'm sorry
i'm even drawing it that's very
fair i mean we're talking about that
earlier we have yet to tape our specials
and it's like i don't know how we're
gonna do it i'd much rather be in your
position
i was listening to sets before this to
remember what
life was before remember what stand-up
was
and because i knew we were going to talk
about this special but i do feel so
disconnected from it but
it gave me the memory of like we are so
lucky to do our jobs and be what they
are and i don't know if i
really was thinking of it that way but
i'm listening and i'm like
this hour especially i am
i worked really hard to even have the
stage be close to the audience i'm very
connected to the audience
um i'm touching them at times i mean not
like
a lot you put your fingers in people's
mouths
i mean i want to i will say super
spreader but you recorded this in
february
right before the shutdown and also
yeah well just to finish this one
thought it is insane well my special's
not gonna work it's all talking about
how come concerts are so crowded these
days
i'm always getting bumped but you're
special it's very connected with the
crowd you have a great stage set up
where you it's like a comedy club where
people are on each side of you
you're ready to even talk to the
audience do i have to pick in the first
four minutes i doubt i i have to pick
someone that's going to kind of stay
with me throughout throughout the
special
a man i thought in this particular
special that man is jeremy
but i had many men throughout the tour
that helped me
wow but i had to make that choice within
like you know i come out i'm looking up
you know how it goes you
you see your crowd you're looking at him
you're looking for the right
guy to pick you almost have to pick
someone who's not frightfully shy
but he looks gentler and a teeny shy
because you want them to know that they
are going to be in good hands so many
people hate sitting up front because i
think they're going to get destroyed
um not my goal at your show absolutely
look at this guy look at your eyebrows
too thick my man
weren't you sick right before oh my gosh
i was i think i got sick in chicago in
january i must have picked something up
i was traveling
and touring you know like three months
straight
um in preparation and i
got sick in january
yes yeah i was just kicking around iraq
in 2004
is it what you that's that's such a
loaded
answer we were sick in january yeah a
super spreader
exactly and it felt like i couldn't get
rid of it
and so of course i don't want to be one
of those people who's like i already had
it but i'm telling you i got sick in
january
i couldn't shake it i feel like i'm
gonna get it
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh no 96 you're clear
cheers to our true drink minimum thank
you
96 years this is official testing this
is better than the testing that we
already have like
maybe it's stress and travel of touring
leading up to it
and but i do like i like to do vocal
warm-ups i come from a musical family
and so i was your mom is a music teacher
right
that's right so we always did some we
did classic warm-ups
did you want me to do it for you yes
please i need some vocal warm-ups
mommy made me mash
[Music]
daddy made me cry myself to
sleep
sisters made me feel real insecure
bumps made me feel real insecure
you know most of the times it's like
unique new york the last one will really
i think appeal to you
the first time i had sex was with a doll
are these not universal i've never heard
them they sound
uh they sound legit though and taken
from the special you have
humped inanimate objects so mr mcdowell
is coming from real life
sometimes i would cheat on the couch
with the end of the bathtub
i was a bit of a humper i guess
here and there it's something i've been
open about um because i was never
described to you
no i think yes i don't know
if you were ever taught it depends on
how your parents taught you
sexuality i know some parents discuss
masturbation with their
with their kids um i remember in my
special you'll remember that
we had a health teacher that talked
about teaching their sons how to
masturbate which i thought was illegal
but if i had been able to get ice cream
after that
can you that's it that's such a weird
mine was like very religious parents it
was very repressed it was never going to
get talked about
so i just feel like pieces from tv and
then well now
he was screaming were your parents
repressed about it was your mom like
yeah it's fine
no my mom never caught me i think if she
caught me hop in the
couch maybe we'd have talked about it
but
now she never made me feel bad or guilt
or anything it was less
i think it was just more of a not
totally discussed thing
than you should be doing certain things
yeah
how's your mom feel about your stand-up
we had a discussion about this
recently especially in regard to to sex
and talking about it because when i
first
started i was very much like uh
very aware of the stereotypes of female
comics like that unfortunately still
exist
13 years later which are women who talk
about sex and so i was like i'm not
gonna talk
about sex i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
repeat jokes and i won't sleep with any
comics
um those were my rules when i first
started at 22. yeah
you know i kept those for a while um
but then i think you become a grown
woman it's like well why can't i offer
my perspective on this it doesn't have
to be some sort of
exploitative graphic description of sex
but um i think it can only help to have
more people's perspective on their
experience and my mom looks at it like
yeah she she doesn't love but she calls
it like body parts humor
like she doesn't love cussing she
doesn't like what are you talking about
your bathroom parts on stage
but i think she's also just like you're
a grown woman and um
some of this isn't going to be for me
all right cheers congratulations on the
special i mean it when i say it's it's
really great i
highly recommend it girl daddy hbo max
thank you beth for joining us
in 2008 my next guest became an internet
sensation and mad tv cast member thanks
to her viral nail salon routine
since then she's appeared on shows like
superstore ugly betty as well as curb
your enthusiasm and released
four one hour specials already on august
20th you can see her hosting the art of
comedy special which was shot at the ha
festival in san antonio please welcome
angela johnson angela thank you for
being here
thank you for having me that was a
mouthful sorry to give you every credit
possible all of it you text me word by
word
once um how are you and your husband
handling
the the quarantine whole lockdown you
know we're actually having a great time
which sometimes i i try not to tell
everybody how much fun we're having
because i know there's love hurt
happening in the world so
i like to be like i hate it but really
ah love it so much
um i'm a homebody love to be home and
we're getting creative
like we all have celebrated birthdays in
quarantine
so far um my husband's birthday is july
so we did christmas in july
because he loves christmas we decorated
we put the christmas tree out
all the decorations everywhere and we
did christmas in july for like a good
three weeks almost the whole month i
feel like you can almost get away with
it in the long term we're at a point
where every day feels the same
i couldn't tell you what the date is
today i feel like if i just saw
christmas decorations like well i guess
this
is christmas now they're probably right
they're probably right dang it yeah i
miss that too
that's why that's why they're drinking
in the middle of the afternoon
uh cheers i'm drinking the ginger max
what do you got over there
cheers
um i watched it last night the the art
of comedy which is a cool way to set up
comedy
oh thanks for watching it yeah and and
you're the host of it
and i don't know maybe you could tell me
maybe wrong but it look like you're
having a lot of fun
what was your favorite part about
shooting the special um my favorite part
about
shooting this special with other comics
is that there was other comics there
because i'm used to being on the road by
myself it's
me my opener my road manager and
that's it and then we're on the road and
then when we come home
most comics will like go hit up the
comedy store the improv
factory whatever a lot of times i just
want to be home
because like i said i'm a homebody i
like that part so i'll do
like dinner with my friends or
just stay home and watch lawn art svu in
my own
bed or my own couch and then pack and
get back on the road again so
a lot of times i'm just with three
people my road manager and my opener and
that's it
so my one of my favorite parts was
the camaraderie with the other comics
and being backstage and then hanging out
after having drinks after and like that
whole thing that was probably
my favorite part was hanging out with
everybody i know what you mean because
when you get to your
success level you always get a little
isolated from what
when you start when you're in the clubs
with everyone every night or you're
just grinding out trying to get sets
anywhere when you get to your level it's
like well now you're just on the road
and yeah you're going to lose people but
then show's over you have really no one
to
decompress with and talk comics talk
away that is
i know you can't be that mean to any
other people who can be mean to comics
they have a special way
it's a nice language yeah we have a
special way
this special was uh a debut for one of
my friends pedro celina so i started out
doing open mics with
no way how cool yeah just like the worst
rooms that we performed in a room that
was a juice bar
and the blender would start immediately
uh which is very exciting it was cool to
see him get his first
tv set for your first set because it's a
different experience
than just doing a club my first tv set
was premium blend on comedy central
years ago
and um it was a bunch of comics and then
they would have like a headliner hosting
it
um jeff dunham was my host the puppet
god yeah
yes and then um on my episode was also
a comic she ended up falling off you may
not have heard of her amy schumer
i don't know did she run
a crawfish room in deep san diego she
used to yeah she used to
do that i think i think she worked at
massage envy now
yeah that's huge that's a huge first
taping
yeah and i like i was i was joking
saying like our careers went at
different paces
but you know what it's fine we're we're
all doing our own journey here
okay well one thing that stood out to me
that i really appreciated
is you get you're hosting this thing not
only did you get everyone's name right
it's crucial
but you gave really nice intros to
everyone we almost feel like you know
the comic before they get up so you
don't have to do that extra step
of digging yourself out be like here's
who i am that's right
i really appreciate the intros you gave
so thank you for doing that and also
i'm sure you've gotten bad intros in
your career
i mean the worst intros
i've witnessed people get some real bad
ones where it's like super cringe-worthy
yeah um one time i was at the improv and
um you know it's one of those nights
where just whoever goes up
and somebody's hosting it and the guy
that was going up next i forget who it
was but he was pretty famous like
more famous for acting than stand-up i
remember but it's like you've seen him
in like so many different movies type of
guy
and whoever was hosting forgot his name
so he does that whole thing where he
goes this next comic
he needs no introduction i mean you've
seen him everywhere
he doesn't even need an intro just come
on out here
and then it's like all of us are like oh
he totally forgot his name clearly
vamping this person what a human being
what a guy that's that's not just a guy
he's also
you know a girl in a way everyone is
everyone and what is the universe even
like oh you're just it's not gonna come
to you also that type of intro like you
donated intro like it better be
the biggest person in the world sure if
you don't say
he doesn't need an intro please welcome
dave chappelle then it's like oh
you forgot his bio then right
right the worst for me is corporate gigs
okay
why this is why because here you are
sitting in this like conference room of
what
tech company blah blah blah right and so
they're not used to
introducing entertainers that's not what
they do they just have like
you know susan from hr who's gonna read
your bio
you know and we're like at the club we
we know like the last thing you hear is
the comics name and then they come up
right and usually at a corporate gig
it's something like
and this performer we're happy to bring
up
angela johnson and then i start walking
out and they go
she has been and then they name
everything i've ever done from the
snickers commercial when i was 23
to like what i did yesterday and then
after like
a good 10 minute intro then they're like
come on out
so you're at this point already on the
stage like well
i heard my name and that's when we know
to go up and then you have to hear
whatever wikipedia thing they downloaded
sure sure sure i remember i got brought
up once we're like and from the
contra it was like my name first and i'm
already on stage just like hunched over
in the dark
and then i was like from the
controversial burger king commercial
here he is like okay well i didn't like
do anything with the burgers it was like
a different reason
i didn't was like there was a
controversial burger king commercial
wait a minute i guess it set off
everyone's like home assistant
alexa or zuri or something and it made
sense oh i didn't know that
yeah well it was like on purpose and
then um
for some reason that made it into the
stage intro and that was
it's a college campus was like wait
controversy what did he do
yeah yeah who do you sleep with
he slept with one of the burgers which i
wouldn't put it past men
yeah yeah in this special the art of
comedy
uh some of the comics perform on a
riverboat which just kind of pitches us
like hell gig because it's like outdoor
boats tourists but i don't know the
longer i don't perform on stage
it was weird watching it because i'm
like i think i'd do that gig now
that was the cool call out in this
special but he doesn't know
uh even gloria is makes an appearance
yeah and special to uh to introduce it
was cool to be a part of something
with her like this and honestly to
acknowledge like our culture
you know what i mean like to acknowledge
that there
are funny latino people
funny like we're really talented and
let's highlight some of us like that
that was an honor to do
because a lot of time i mean like we're
we're making fun like diversity matters
though and so
yeah that's why i was really super
honored to be a part of
this special and hosting it because
i want to see our stories told and you
know
like we deserve that they're great
stories
yeah there's a really cool way that hbo
max framed it and that it's the art of
comedy and it's not
billed as these shows we get to feature
these people that just have interesting
points of views
and kind of the fact that they're latin
or spanish has really nothing to do with
just that they're good at stand up
because a lot of times when you first
start your career it's like well we need
a separate night for all the latin
people
it's i see saturdays oh i did refried
fridays for many years
nothing feels better than getting a
check that says refried fridays on it
just from my name alone uh it doesn't
seem like just a bland white guy name i
would get put on
chocolate sundaes really urban show
yeah oh yeah yeah okay two of them name
alone
i think i did it like once or twice
chocolate some days angela this was so
much fun talking to you
thank you so much for doing the show
you're so funny and it's really special
that i got to be on this
with you so thank you for having me art
of comedy is the special
and cheers yes i would like to thank all
of my guests rose matt defeo beth
stelling angela johnson whose
specials are all part of the summer
comedy festival on hbo max
hopefully you'll find specials from
chris red and i up there at some point
and then there's two specials that are
hosted by my boss and guy holding the
ring light
conan o'brien thank you for joining us
for team coco live's moses and friends
good night
[Music]
you